my name is Stephanie Vina I'm a
professor at Q tech TU delft and I'm
working with a team of people from
physics and computer science in order to
build a quantum Internet
a quantum Internet fundamentally
enhances the internet technology that we
have today it enables us to send quantum
bits qubits from one point on the
Internet to another and by doing this we
can implement applications that are
impossible on the internet that we have
today
a quantum Internet has many applications
and one application that I'm quite
excited about is secure quantum
computing in the cloud on my quantum
internet you could use a very simple
quantum device a quantum terminal to
perform a computation on a remote
quantum computer in such a way that the
quantum computer cannot learn what
computation you're performing this is
interesting for example to perform a
simulation on this quantum computer of a
preparatory new material this way you
can perform that simulation that's no
classical computer might be able to do
in such a way that you don't have to
give away your material design
so we are building a quantum network in
the Netherlands which might become a
world's first in which we connect
quantum processors small quantum
computers in different cities the first
link will be built between our location
here in Delft and a place in The Hague
with a Dutch telecom we then want to
expand this network to other cities and
also want to make it available to you in
a few years from now